taylor swift stepping it up with joe
alwyn dedicating her new bonus track the
lakes to her bow of three years
take me to the lakes where all the poets
went to die
i don't belong and never love it neither
do you
the song is only available on the
physical album folklore which hit stores
today
the lyrics describe the lakes district
in the uk where taylor and joe
spent their third anniversary last fall
in private
i'm not cut out for
all these cynical clones
these hunters with cell phones
and leave it to taylor to take another
shot at a nemesis
we're thinking scooter brawn
[Music]
next cardi b and megan stallion's racy
new song and video
i don't cook i don't clean but let me
tell you i got this
ring and i really wanted like the video
to be very sexy very clean very nice
very cut
my baby's joking the mom to two-year-old
culture and megan who is still
recovering from her gunshot wounds
dropped their collab whap last night
kylie jenner normani and
others joined them in the wild video
which had to be censored
version of the song in the music video
is the sensor version
because we speaking some nasty
it hurt my feelings but i like pain it
just really meant
a lot for everybody to be in this video
i feel like i'm
rebirthing myself for something like i
don't know what it is
cardi tells apple music she's frustrated
with the pandemic
oh corona virus that's kind of
uncomfortable like i want to be around
like i want to do an interview like this
is weird to me
and i want to i want a tour i want to i
want to tour i don't know they got to do
a coronavirus tylenol so
could go away real camera next behind
the scenes of gaga and ariana's hit
collab
[Music]
gaga posted their crazy rain on me
choreography rehearsal
complete with hugs someone hurt lady
gaga scratched my eyes
and this maternal maneuver no no no no
no no no no
i wanted to say that to your mom oh my
god you're two days older than me
you have a scratch on your face you
can't get infected before the video
come shoot day there was only gratitude
and finally a country star delivers for
his fans
i'll probably drop a couple songs just
to keep people you know a little bit
happy
just one day after telling us that
morgan wallin revealed he's dropping the
song seven summers next friday
fans first heard a demo clip last month
and took to social media
begging him to release it e.t has an
exclusive preview
[Music]
the 27 year old former voice contestant
also shocked fans last month
by revealing he's a dad posting this
shot with son wilder
what kind of dad do you want to be i had
a really good example of a dad growing
up
that's what i want to be it's definitely
changed the way i look at things i
realize that every decision i make now
don't just affect me
but you know really affects him too so
try to be a little bit more responsible